the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I want to talk with you about
how it is that we can do research of a
scientific kind for something as complex
as human behavior you know as opposed to
things that you measure out in space or
test tubes or under microscopes people
are complex organisms right it's do
research on them to understand human
nature how the mind works how the brain
supports it is a challenging story so
usual thing is an experiment you have a
group of participants I will talk about
that but in the reading for today and I
know for the first time we've done this
so you may not have read it but if you
have that'd be great is it kind of
another thread of the kind of way that
people are studied which is dramatic
individual stories with case studies
single stories that are illustrative of
something that we think are broader
principles and a lot of our biggest
discoveries and we'll come to that later
in the course have been made on very
unusual single individuals who turn out
to have a lesson that's pretty broad for
for example for the organization of the
human brain so in the Oliver Sacks book
there's a story about Donald and what
did Donald do that got him in big
trouble yeah her girlfriend while he was
on PCP he's in a psychiatric hospital
they try hypnosis to help him remember
it he says he doesn't remember it many
of you may know that an astounding
number of criminals under uh under
interrogation tell you they don't
remember anything about the episode
involved right it's so people are
suspicious at first for many reasons
because the easiest thing to say is I
don't remember
what happened and then you can't catch
yourself in a lie or any complexity
right because you don't remember what
happened and sometimes you don't
remember and sometimes you do but in
this case they try hypnosis that doesn't
help he's in there for four years and
then he knows conceptually that he
murdered his girlfriend and he says I'm
not fit for society he knows it's a
terrible thing he did but it's kind of
like an intellectual knowledge right
it's not a feeling it's not a memory and
then um he has he goes biking and
something happens which is
he gets hit by a car and so there's what
appears to be a drug induced amnesia of
the original murderous episode he gets
hit by a car is a severe head injuries
in a coma for two weeks he has
left-sided weakness as he comes out of
it which means the biggest injury was in
the right side of his brain weakness and
numbness and he has frontal lobe
contusions he has injury and bleeding
around the frontal lobes and cortex that
sits in the front of the brain but now a
remarkable thing happens it is it - but
you know - insults two wrongs made a
right the first wronged being the PCP
the second wronged being the accident
and now what happens he remembers in
vivid and Florida tale the horror that
he actually committed this murder this
is it - insults to the brain one
drug-induced one a focal injury
repressed the memory and an
unrepresented ooh is discover whether he
really has his memory or he just thinks
he has this memory and how do they
figure out to their satisfaction whether
it's a really recovered memory or a
fabrication of his mind right that's
really important he remembers details of
the murder that are not publicly
available that were not in the
information that was given to him that's
a really huge issue in these kinds of
memories so there's a really recovered
memory not a inadvertently fabricated
memory and they discover he has a deep
seizure activity in his limbic
structures the parts of his brain that
are involved in emotion are having a
seizure Zappa lepsy neurons are firing
for no good reason and that's part of
his disorder they give him medications
to help with that but here's the
question for you for a moment to think
about and it's now such a common
question because their society is moving
that way that it's on many TV shows I
see it like every couple of weeks is a
law-and-order episode that has something
like this which is uh the more you know
about the biology underlies that really
criminal terrible behavior should that
be a cost for understanding it or not
okay so in this case he took the drugs
he killed the person you think he's
pretty responsible but how about
somebody who kills somebody and it turns
out in such a case a man with no history
a grown man with no history of criminal
activity of any kind
shoved his wife out of a high window to
her death in the course of a standard
argument all right
then they discovered that he has a big
tumor growing in the basal part of his
frontal cortex now is the man
responsible for what he did it's a
really interesting question right and
the more we understand about the
neuroscience of our brains what makes us
do things which lets us control impulses
what makes us murderous there's a guy
Kent Kiehl University Mexico he's
driving around in a big van with an MRI
scanner and he goes from penitentiary to
penitentiary and he images the brains of
serial murderers of psychopathic
murderers okay and he's getting things
are pretty systematically different
about their brains and a question is you
know what does that mean does that mean
those people were prone to do it for
reasons of their early environment or
genes or some incident had happened if
that's the case do you forgive them
differently should we have a moral
different moral code or legal code as we
discovered the brain basis for some of
these things or is that irrelevant what
counts as the action so this is kind of
thing you could think about maybe
discuss in your section some the more we
understand about the human brain the
more we'll understand about behaviors
that we find terrible and what does that
mean about legal and moral decisions
about how to punish those or think about
those so that's coming in your lifetime
because there's steady progress on this
and understand how to think about that
is a really big question so and we
talked with you today about research in
psychology and a funny thing about
psychology and I'll come back to this is
everybody is an amateur psychologist
they have to be if you deal with people
you're an amateur psychologist moreover
we live in a world with Oprah Winfrey
and dr. Phil right so in case you're
only an amateur one you hear all kinds
of stuff newspaper internet magazines
everywhere you go friends will tell you
stuff about psychologists I found this
or psychologists have found that right
so you have your own intuitions to deal
with people in everyday life and here's
a kind of a sentence from Time magazine
you know that uh you know drives
psychologists crazy if you take it
seriously so here's here's this literal
sentence almost half of children of
divorces enter adulthood as
worried underachieving self-deprecating
and sometimes angry young men and women
okay so that sounds kind of like a
psychological study of some kind kind of
right you know somebody who wants to
argue about the importance of divorce
and breakdown of the family this is a
kindly so let's think about this for a
moment
almost half of children of divorce enter
adulthood is worried are you guys
worried about global warming a little
are you worried about peace in the
Middle East and how that influences
Middle East and the u.s. a little are
you worried about economy that may not
have jobs waiting for you a little okay
who's not worried a little a little bit
of the time so almost so it doesn't even
tell you what half of children in the
world for example are who come from
families without divorce right because
that's the only relevant question it's
not our people worried about stuff
underachieving
compared to what how would you prove
somebody's underachieving
scientifically okay I mean we most of
you probably we've had days where you've
underachieved
in days we've achieved pretty well but
how would you measure and prove that
self-deprecating well sometimes he
thinks actually kind of nice of a
person's modest okay what's the
difference between modest and
self-deprecation and i like this one
sometimes angry young men and women
right okay i mean you know i mean it's
yeah are you sometimes angry about
something or another okay and if you are
does that tell us that society is
breaking down and your parents did
something bad that you're sometimes i
mean who is a human being is not
sometimes angry so here's a kind of
psychology sounding sentence on a
serious topic which is you know what is
divorce consequences of divorces and
families and you know should we be
thinking about things that encourage
marriages to stay stable and things like
that
but there's really no information at all
right so from a from a research or
science perspective so I'm going to talk
about a little bit just reminding you
what science is we're at a university
obviously that this thinks about science
and does science all the time that
remind you of what an experiment is a
very brief history of psychology
experimentation and then walk you
through a few experiments that I find
kind of interesting and then some topics
related to psychology so let me start
with this how do you know what is true
how do you know what is true that you
take to be true
what is the answer looking out like how
do I know hopefully filming
okay well when people try to analyze
this and you can think about it for your
own self one of them is Authority
parents teachers textbooks scientists
professors and courses we tell you this
is the truth right and if you remember
the truth correctly you get an A so you
know Authority is a huge source I mean
right it would be costly to go around
and kinda have your own idea about
everything twelve inches in a foot I'm
not taking that piece of information
without skeptic I mean you'd have to you
couldn't leave your life without kind of
believing a lot of stuff but you know
you don't want to believe everything
right you just because you hear it
repetition or tenacity you hear
something often enough and people tend
to believe stuff a priori what's
reasonable he thinks thinks through just
by thought what's possible rational and
so on and you know then maybe a fourth
brand of knowledge to something a
scientific analysis where we have
hypotheses and we test them in some
version of experiments or at least
correlations among data now there's
another view which is kind of a that
whatever we think makes something
science is what the scientific community
decides as a community is true right
roughly speaking that is if the mainstay
of faculty at places like MIT and
Stanford and Harvard and so on and
around the world at universities tell
you this is you know how science works
you go okay that's how science works and
I remember some years ago there was
there was a lot of excitement about a a
satirical article written by a scientist
where he said oh this is all just
societal authority scientists tell you
what's true just because they believe in
it just like you know sports writer says
the Celtics are the best you don't
really think that the sports writer
knows scientifically the Celtics are the
best right okay so you know so and he
wrote a paper saying that gravity is
simply a consensus among scientists and
a particular view they're forcing on
society okay but none of us would want
to really go up there jump out the
window going well gravity is you know
one person's opinion and here's my
opinion right okay so some but it's kind
of interesting because you know for
those of you who go to medical school
for example you learn lots of procedures
and so on to the medical committee
believes is true where there's not much
scientific evidence behind it but they
have to use it every day
so you know you're used to hearing about
the scientific method it applies to
psychology in many ways just like it
applies to chemistry physics or biology
we have to test things that are
falsifiable we have to deal in
probabilities of outcomes in terms of
statistics in some sense the kinds of
data we can have our descriptive or
correlative or experimental I'll talk
about those in a moment we are always
trying to disprove the null hypothesis
statistically as you know which we can't
prove that something is true but we can
prove that it's not true and then
finally like all fields of science the
most exciting today's most exciting
breakthroughs are tomorrow's things that
have to be apologized for and
rediscovered right okay I mean what
makes something breaking science is not
that it's known with certainty with no
uncertainty is what's in your textbook
kind of what makes something breaking
Sciences it moves the field forward
so what's the difference between the
cutting edge and the bleeding edge is a
very close call so here's a cartoon that
says it's he's constantly proving his
experiments wrong okay and the guys kind
of glum looking over he's proving the
null hypothesis to be correct now that's
sort of funny for scientists but it's a
sort of funny in the sense that no we
don't really go around going I hope you
know with all my heart for this research
project I've worked on for the last five
years that it will prove the null
hypothesis there's no difference between
things I'm studying in fact scientists
like all humans have agendas and hopes
and like everybody else so they observe
hypothesize experiment this is data it
doesn't always go perfectly right and
the last thing I want to say is I'm
going to emphasize today a scientific
approach to the human mind and behavior
but of course there's many other paths
of knowledge for important things in our
life religion philosophy arts and so on
there's many things that science cannot
address and I don't want to pretend that
it does you know that's not a problem
too much when you think about chemistry
it's kind of an interesting problem you
think about psychology because we think
about happiness or values or things like
that those topics cut across psychology
and things like religion philosophy and
topics like that so what makes something
an experiment is you have to have sort
of two things conceptually especially
the
dependent variable what you measure the
outcome and the independent variable
what you vary once you have those things
at an experiment you're kind of an
experiment in a broad sense so in
psychology it took a long time it was
until the 1800s that people had kind of
an approach to doing experiments in
psychology and figuring out for example
how to use the simple measurement of
time to measure how long a mental
operation lasts in your mind so that's
pretty cool if you were to come to a
fifth-grader and say how would you
measure not a you know a brick or a
stone but how long a thought takes you'd
say well that'd be pretty hard but it
turns out it's not as hard in a simple
way so Wilhelm wants a big figure in
psychology first textbook in psychology
first laboratory in psychology did the
following test of mental chronometry
simply measuring how long it takes you
to do things so he would which he would
show you a light and he'd simply press
the button and that would take about
twenty a fifth of a second and then he
would say instead let's you do this if
the light turns on in this red you push
one button and if it's green you push
another so his idea was the motor system
to push the button is about the same the
time to observe the light is about the
same but the difference between these
two is how long it takes to make a
choice how long it takes to make a
choice and that difference when he
subtracts them took about a tenth of a
second by that measurement so all of a
sudden you could start to measure in an
objective sense how long a mental
operation takes in your mind then
psychology went a lot of different
directions a famous one from Tichenor
who worked with ones developed a
psychology department at Cornell was
introspection look inside yourself and
think very carefully when you think
about a topic how do I think about it
that lost its way as a scientific method
trouble is you know one person thinks
one way one person thinks another way
and you can't really settle it right so
it's a introspection about your thoughts
as a private process it's not a public
measure that you can exchange among
scientists like time or measurements but
we still introspect a lot when we think
about psychology whether it feels right
to us what are the questions to ask the
still just being human you can't help
but introspect about psychology topics
in the US
there was a sort of a huge response and
to to introspection as being too loose
too loosey-goosey one famous name and
this is John Watson he said the mind is
unobservable so we can only study
behavior things that people do actions
they take their mouth moves or hand
buttons presses and then we identify
what in the environment influences those
behaviors the principles of the mind
should be similar between animals and
humans and that the only thing
responsible experimental scientist can
do is relate environmental factors to
actions and so there's a stimulus and
you can control the stimulus as a
scientist there's a response you measure
the response and that's your psychology
experiment and then the 1980s became the
cognitive revolution partly this path
led to not after a while - not very
interesting science that was the biggest
problem and people said no we can make
inferences about the mind as it
translates what it hears or sees into
what a person does so ideas of
representations or knowledge in the mind
or in the brain later on and how that
translates what's out there and how you
act upon it so I'll remind you a couple
more things then we'll get to specifics
so correlations are you can only get in
an experiment right we have an
independent variable we sorry
correlations you can look at all the
time experiments only experiments allows
us to infer causation so let's pick an
example that when I read struck me is
slightly relevant so age of parent and
risk for disease in a child so you're
most of you are young enough that you're
not too worried about this yet and you
have no reason to be but for those of us
who are my generation in some
generations back many people are
postponing childbirth as they do their
careers and complete different tasks and
they're getting older and parents are
getting older note it only seemed old
they are old okay so it's too is the
case statistically that the older the
mother is that higher the risk of Down
syndrome so the statistics are f of
mothers aged 20 to 24 it's very rare
tap Down syndrome and the number goes up
dramatically that the mother is aged
over age 42 so this is simply
observation and measurement but it's
something a lot of women giving birth in
their 30s and 40s are thinking about and
worrying
it's a thing on their mind up until
relatively recently men said oh it's too
bad for those women but we're no problem
for us yeah
so you're the movie star right who's 90
years old and marries a 20 year old
actress right you know that kind of
model that you see all the time in the
news because it doesn't matter how old a
guy as well it turns out you know it
does matter
and here's some data for that so here's
the probability of developing
schizophrenia a disease that's only
that's typically diagnosed in a person's
late adolescence or 20s depending on the
age of the father and you can see the
father is less than 25 it's one out of
141 if the father is in this 50s it
becomes one out of 50 a dramatic growth
in the likelihood of the offspring child
having schizophrenia depending on the
age of the father
okay so now there's a correlation
between age and whether a child
expresses schizophrenia so let's guess
about the possible causes of that I can
tell you it's unknown but let's even
begin to guess about it let me ask you
to guess about
yeah yeah bad sperm right okay it's not
for some reason in some way and sperm
that leads more likely to be risk for
schizophrenia so that's a good that's
that's your first intuition and that may
turn out to be right problematic
something problematic about the sperm
from the male here's another one though
and this is shows you you know you know
the challenges with a correlational
research on something even so important
as this which is how about held on 24
inches who marries later in life okay
yeah you know maybe the desirable men
are plucked off the market on average
and large statistics by age 30 or
something and a bunch of us and I'm a
late merrier you know limp to find some
woman around the world who will accept
us okay and finally out of pity some
woman says okay you drag yourself into
your 50s and I'll I'll take you you know
so ah right because it's not random
probably this is we're averaging over
many people but it's not random probably
who marries a 25 in a given society and
who marriage is a 50 it's not random it
could be big differences among okay how
could we tell that difference maybe it's
nothing to do with the sperm maybe it's
something to do with the something about
the genes and environment that goes with
marrying you know being a parent in your
50s versus being a parent in your 20s
completely different explanations
someday maybe we'll know but we don't
know now all right so this is the limits
of correlations and you know could be
both could be true neither could be a
third story altogether so that was about
me Mya might be coming up here in too
late in life and marrying late in life
let's talk about you alright so let's
talk about the level of stress you have
and how empathetic you are on average
your college generation relative to
one's 5 or 10 or 20 years ago so let's
ask that question why would people want
to know such a thing well you might want
understand you know what what pressures
are we putting young people under as
they go through grade school and high
school with in college you know what's
what's the worm like is it pretty much
the same as it pretty much changing you
know
now how would we figure that how will we
begin to measure that it's a very simple
question are you more stressed than
people 10 years ago at MIT on average
across the country and now you're more
or less empathetic towards other people
how might one answer that kind of a
question yeah that would be a very
interesting path
it's a tough research path but you're
right you some if we had some biological
signature of stress that would be good
one but listen let's ask this question
let's say I measured everybody in here
and got your average stress hormone or
something like that now what's my answer
about whether 10 years ago people were
more or less stressed yeah that's would
be awesome yeah no yeah sadly an extreme
outcome of stress of a kind but there's
a lot of things that going ok so so we
have to worry about two things one thing
we don't know one thing we know is let
me ask you another one you could compare
your level of stress to people who are
10 years older than you or 20 years
older than you what do you think about
that no yeah yeah
yeah because maybe people at 20 or maybe
people who are 30 or 40 are more
stressed for other reasons because they
have more bills and mortgages to pay or
less trust for other reasons or whatever
right maybe that's not about the
generation you're in maybe it's about
being a person with more
responsibilities at 40 right okay so
here's for some things you get some luck
and you have it in your hand so here's
an emotional health questionnaire where
students across the country for the last
25 years have been given the identical
question error it's a questionnaire it's
not a biology measure about their
self-reported measure of stress okay and
this was on the New York Times just a
few weeks ago it's you guys on average
across the country us college students
are an all time high level of
self-reported stress all right sorry
about that yeah yeah so it's not the
perfect measurement every way but it's
the same questionnaire to college
students year in year out by self-report
people say I feel more stressed you can
also see that there's a difference
between men and women women on average
report on average report feeling more
stressed and it may be relevant and on
average for example it's a higher rate
of depression among women than men
there's a much higher rate of autism
among men than women so it's not it's
not a you know have been one sex or the
other is not a gift certificate area of
avoiding a mental health challenges but
you know these so you're more stressed
than ever okay good luck I've well try
to the best weekend in this course to
not warming that way worse but you know
that's something to think about I you
know I got a call the other day from
somebody said there's a lot of curiosity
about whether the shift from book
learning and book reading to internet
world's and Twitter and Facebook worlds
are fundamentally changing how people
think and that sounds kind of possible
okay and there are people who give
amazingly entertaining lectures about
these things scientifically it's
unbelievably hard to imagine how we
would ever answer that so when I get a
casual phone call like you know what
what did neuroscientist know about that
what could they know about it you know
is that an even an answerable question
if I take you now and say well you've
probably done more Facebook than a 50
year old and compared you to a 50 year
old on some other thing is that going to
answer the question of how you think
about ideas given the world you live in
versus the world a 50 year old liftin no
so there's just a lot of huge deep
things about changes in the world that
we can't even begin to get at sometimes
we get lucky and people have been giving
some particular measure for some time
empathy
by self-report and now you if this you
know I wouldn't fill it out now but you
can take a look just to get a feeling
without your fill your leisure this is
the questionnaire they used for
self-reported empathy it's self-report
forty percent lower today than twenty
years ago yeah so on average you guys
literally call it on average by these
measures are more stressed and less
empathetic towards others okay and those
sorry okay and those things as this is
not an individual this is an average
right so the levels that society
operates things are going on and moving
and for some reason by the way I can
tell you that what I'm stressed I have
less room to be empathetic okay so maybe
these students are related if you're
feeling stressed your first thought is
not how can I help others but like how
can I just get through the day okay so
these these things might be related so
let's turn a little bit to
experimentation so and some of the
challenges of relating psychology to
real-world policies that are meant to
make the world better or safer in some
way so there's a famous a broken window
theory from the political scientist
James Wilson the criminologist George
Kelling and their other deal was this
that especially in neighborhoods that
are not immaculately kept or were to say
the other way where there's a lot of
damage around you things like broken
windows is the phrase they used that
this promotes in people who live in that
community or work around the community a
sense that you know the rules don't
count anybody can do anything and then
it fosters the growth of petty crimes
and once you do a petty crime you're
more vulnerable or willing to do a major
crime a slippery slope okay
and in fact there
Rudy Guiliani and Commissioner Bill
Bratton employed this they asked the
police to write lots of tickets and make
lots of sort of minor arrests for things
where people weren't up keeping the
environment or where they were littering
or things like that and this is a huge
debate because in a Police Department
you can only do so much so if they put
if they have a person working on
jaywalking and littering that's a person
not working on you know major crime
rings okay so they make it to try to
make a choice where they think they can
make communities safer in the most
effective way and the crimes went way
down in New York in most cities now you
don't hear crime discussed as a big
topic nationally in some local areas
like in Boston some specific areas you
do you know I don't remember there was a
word about crime that I can remember a
week ago okay it's not a big national
topic in some local places it is a big
topic but not nationally so you don't
know it some years ago when people said
New York City was a horrible place to go
because there was so much crime then
you'd walk out from your plane and get
mugged before you made it to your taxi
no it was you know it was like the whole
country was saying big cities were just
crime you know crime ridden and
dangerous they do this policy things get
better right survey said hmm that sounds
pretty good but of course it's not an
experiment it's a real-life policy and
then people had these kind of you know
incredibly clever reinterpretations of
why crime went down so the most you know
the most of the wildest one was was in
Freakonomics was discussed in that which
said well abortion was legalized in 1973
that gave women who didn't have access
to legal abortions the ability to have
them that the children on average in
these communities that at least access
to safe and legal abortions would be
poor unstable addicted addiction ridden
communities statistically and that so
that if you imagine the reduced abortion
rate in poor areas could when you count
out the number of possible criminals in
those areas account for the reduction in
crime all by itself a completely
different interpretation that has
nothing to do with the policy it just
said we're going to have a demographic
shift which will have a weird unexpected
sequence of lowering the crime rate
because it's defining that young men in
particular are most likely to engage in
violent criminal activities not a rule
but a statistical average or there was a
big cracka demmick that crack academic
that reduced or lots of states put in
laws that put people into jail for much
higher longer periods much more severe
penalties with new drug laws so it's
very hard to know if the policy that was
initiated really worked or whether
completely other things were happening
that move the crime rates and here's
some very you know sort of perverse or
other explanations so that left the
question is it's broken windows even a
good idea just because you're Harvard
and we know Harvard is always right
but just because a Harvard psychologist
says pretty interestingly that sounds
right to me
is that even a right idea okay so let's
take a step back can we test that
experimentally so here's the experiment
and the idea is again that when people
observe that others violate a social
norm or legitimate rule are they more
likely to violate if you see people
around you breaking rules are you more
likely to do it and you could say it
seems like it is but let's do the
science so here's an independent measure
I'll show you the environment the
dependent measure is it a number of
people who perform a violation now you
can't go getting people murdering each
other and stuff for an experiment but
you can do this this is a you can have
two conditions on the top condition do
you ever go back to your car or bike
usually cars I think and they put
leaflets in your car and now what are
you going to do you're running away the
LEAs little leaflet on your windshield
wiper so they put it out and either had
a wall like this which was clean there's
a sign that says no graffiti and they
put on those white pieces of paper onto
the bikes or they put a lot of graffiti
on the wall okay and people came out
from their classes they went in the
glasses they parked their bike they ran
into class they came out and they got
all these white leaflets and what they
did is watched and they said how many
people put the leaflet away and how many
people crumpled it up and threw it right
on the ground
okay so you we don't know what they're
going to do with the leaflet they put it
away but we could hope they're going to
throw it out one thing we know for sure
if you crumple it up and throw it on the
ground is littering and not a good
social norm and sure enough a third of
the people littered if the wall had no
graffiti but it
more than doubled at the wall had
graffiti so that's a small thing that's
not a broken-down complicated
neighborhood but just at that moment as
you roar out of class you get that piece
of paper on your bike and you see like
wow this is pretty crummy place people
are breaking the rules all the time
twice as likely to throw a piece of
paper on the ground so that shows that
people very easily are influenced by
very mild perceptions of whether people
are following rules or not and will be
there better cells or their worst selves
depending on that sense of you know are
all rules on or all rules off and
there's a pretty good bet they're not
thinking about it right another thing
they're saying there okay here's a you
know here's littering you know not as
bad as killing somebody or as litter
here's the wall well there's 30%
graffiti I mean nobody does that they
have an emotion quick response but the
environment makes a difference in that
regard so an important thing about on
studies are this so let me tell you
about this one here's a study that to
look at a drug that was supposed to
lower mortality from coronary artery
disease those who took the drug 80% or
more because people follow whether you
take the drug if you don't take the drug
of course the drug won't work
I had a 15% mortality rate within five
years those who took the drug less than
80% had a 25 percent mortality so you'd
say well 10% better chance of living for
five years that's worth it right um the
nice thing is they had a placebo and
there was no difference whatsoever
between those who took the active drug
and those who took the placebo the
differences between was those who
followed the instructions to take the
pill and those who didn't so what does
that mean how do you interpret that it's
not the drug yeah
it could be that it could be the stress
it couldn't be that well let me make a
guess there's no scientific answer to
this people who tend not to follow
instructions are they mostly stressed by
not following instructions
no that mostly the intuition is there
blowing it off they're like yeah that's
the instructions but I got things to do
in places we go but you could be right
um so anyway the idea is what you pick
up is are people who try to take care of
themselves they have a they have a
health condition and the people who are
following the pill instruction are
probably also doing the best they can in
terms of exercise diet all the things
they could do to maximize their health
right okay and they're taking their
placebo or they're taking the drug they
don't know right but they're doing
everything they can
and the people who blowing off stuff
they're the ones who are doing all the
things that aren't health including not
even taking your pills I mean if you
don't even take your pills right I mean
exercises work diet is work popping a
pill that's been handed to you that
you're told might help you is probably
not that much work so you know that says
it's what's called self selection bias
that you stand out if you tend to take
care of yourself or not okay so when we
run experiments that universities would
involve people a huge issue for us is
the idea is this that we randomly
recruit people and we'll come back to
this in a moment then we randomly
assigned them to one condition or
another for example the placebo
condition or the drug conditioner we
randomly assigned them to the messy wall
or the clean wall we discover something
and then we try to generalize it as far
as we can to people as a whole we've
discovered something fundamental about
how humans work generalizable principles
of human mind of behavior so what really
happens in the world and you know it's
always you're in between sort of the
best possible world in the world we
actually live in so is it really who
really is it really random who
participates in research studies that
you in psychology departments a lot of
the research gets done
is it really random no okay so who
volunteers have any of you volunteer to
be a subject of an experiment anywhere
yeah okay so it's not random you know
it's that some people they either need
to make a few bucks or they're very
curious about psychology or they you
have a friend who's in psychology or you
know it's not
and in fact population-wide people have
this said that psychology could be
described as weird research for the
following reason
that the vast majority of the findings
you'll read about everywhere including
in your textbook but everywhere are from
nations that are westernized educated
industrialized and relatively rich them
democracies okay the vast majority are
between 17 and 25 they're undergraduates
or graduate students who participate in
research it's been estimated if your us
college students you're four thousand
times more likely to show up in a
scientifically reported experiment than
if you're a person anywhere else on the
planet okay
four thousand times because why because
it's changing a little bit but for many
many years you know the huge amount of
research happen in the u.s. at
universities pretty much a better
universities pretty much at highly
selected students all right so that's
and then we never published that we
never say MIT students did the following
thanks people's guy at MIT students you
know because then we have a different
report from Stanford or from UMass or
from Michigan or Texas we say no humans
did an experiment and humans are like
this okay
so and that could make is it's just
something to think about as you see
studies and stuff like that people are
more and more sensitized to that so more
and more of the world gets somewhat
industrialize --is there's more and more
research around the world but still the
vast majority of findings are you guys
okay now that's just to start with who's
in the subject pool or the participant
pool how normal are you when you do an
experiment no matter are you like
yourself or are you doing weird stuff
and people use this idea that you're
really weird when you do an experiment
in another sense because like you don't
know what's going on you're following
instructions you know so they do
experience to show how ridiculously
people behave yeah when they're doing
experiment like they would never do it
so they they ask them to feel come in
and they say would you feel out 200
sheets of paper filled with random
digits add them pairwise and just I'll
come back in a few hours now if a friend
asked you to do that add random digits
for a couple hours he was like no thank
you I've got about eight million better
things to do than that right I could
multiply random digits to start with her
so but people will do it for hours
because they're in this weird like I
mean you know I get asked the
instruction and that's what I'm
mission is or even more ridiculous it
pick up a card after each page they've
added all these numbers you know for no
good reason and the instruction tells
them when you've done the page chaired
the page up into 32 pieces and here's
the next page okay the next page
it's obviously fruitless and pointless
ridiculously so but because you're in an
experiment and somebody told you to do
that right you just keep barreling
forward so yeah how much are we are who
we are when we do experiments versus
people falling weird instructions and
we'll come back to that and some serious
context that's the subjects how about
experimenters experimenters are never
objective we try to be as scientists as
objective as we can we're never you know
we believe certain hypotheses we have
certain goals we recognize results that
would be super exciting we recognize
results that would be boring okay we're
humans too we want to do stuff that
matters we want to do stuff that people
reward us for it means just human so
here's here's a lowest case example of
how once you're an experimenter you
produce your own results and believe me
it's much more when you result matters
for things like your career advancement
or your your status in the field so
students were told that rats were either
maize bright or maize dal they were told
these rats were bred to be smart
learners or not so smart the rats were
all just random rats okay it's a fake
story to undergraduates then they had
them on a test on a maze and they said
any for your laboratory exercise write
down how quickly the rat runs the maze
okay and then amazingly the smart rats
did way better than the dull rats okay
now these are not students trying to
become famous or have a period of
handing in an assignment okay how did
that happen well they went back and it
wasn't that anybody fake did everything
like that but well they looked at films
or discuss stuff with kids it students
in the course every little thing that
the students did that move the data in
little tiny tiny ways always favored
finding the maze bright rats being
brilliant maze runners so for example
you know they would put the rat if
you've ever run a rat in a maze has
anybody run the rat in a maze is it easy
it even if you picked them up and
putting them in the maze that's when
they're not more automated now is it
physically easy i racks like please I'm
show me the starting line I'm ready to
go no what are they like help me out
here for you guys
are they kind of school are they kind of
really at and they don't like to be
handled actually no even ones and Leon
they're likelier there's flighty and
these are undergraduates have hardly
ever touched a rat okay they're like
please don't attack me or something it's
other they're holding replicas and the
rats fighting back and because it's
really uncomfortable that's really
unhappy that students like really yeah
it's uh you know so what happens is edit
and then they clunk the rat down and the
oh my gosh is facing the wrong direction
and it's a smart one wait let's start
start stop the clock let's get him you
know but if it's a dull one facing the
wrong direction
it's okay it's a dull one let the maze
right so lots of little things are you
sure you wrote this down was a twelve
seconds or eleven I guess it was eleven
oh because it's a smart one okay so
completely innocently completely
innocently as far as we understand they
made the result to match up with what
the expectation was and it's not just
that and if you know this example you
know cognitive psychologists have
studied a phenomenon like this so try
this at your desk each card is a letter
on one side and a number on the other
side your job is to figure out what's
the smallest number of cards you have to
pick up to discover if this rule is
right if a card has a vowel on one side
then it has an even number on the other
side so think about this for a moment if
a card has a vowel on one side then it
has to have an even number on the other
side what's the smallest number of cards
you can pick up to test that hypothesis
so here's what's people have found the
correct answer is e and seven and about
ten percent of people on average come up
with that many many more people C pick e
alone or e + 6 Y well everybody gets
that you have to look at e because it's
an even number right so you flip e over
and if that one turns out to have it's a
vowel if it has an odd number that the
rule the hypothesis is wrong right
that's everybody gets it you should
check e pretty much everybody gets that
a J is irrelevant because it's a
consonant okay now comes the interesting
six and seven because it's because if
the sentence is talking about a vowel
and an even number sometimes people feel
I gotta check the even
right but it doesn't say anything about
even numbers couldn't go with consonants
it doesn't even it doesn't tell you
anything that's not that's not part of
the hypothesis so you don't you Det but
you but if you flipped over number seven
and you discovered a vowel you'd violate
the rule so what happens is they're
tempted to go for things that feel like
they confirm the question and it feels
like e confirms it and it feels like six
confirms it right and it's what's called
confirmatory bias that when you look at
stuff if you see what you think confirms
it
then you tend to go for that even when
there's evidence in front of you that
could contradict your expectation okay
so now I'm going to give you a practical
date to the practical suggestion for how
to win somebody over if you have a
blueing romantic interest in that person
all right all right so finally we get
practical right everything is like okay
you go I'm not running rats you know I'm
a taking all right all right
and I think it's really interesting
because I think you know when we think
about how people make decisions in their
lives we tend to think intuitively about
big decisions you know what's my career
going to be where do I go to college we
think those are the big decisions but a
huge amount of life is little decisions
moment to moment if somebody asked his
four sons you say yes or no somebody
walks up to you at party they did want
to talk with you do you feel like
talking or not feel like talking you
know maybe you talk with them as a
lifetime friend or romantic partner or
whatever so Lou I think we make
constantly little decisions that turn
out to big effects in our lives so
here's some evidence about things like
that that influence that and this is a
work that Yale so we describe people as
warm or we can define them as cold or
aloof right and we could think those
words are kind of arbitrary and most of
us if you met somebody at a party would
you rather hang out with somebody who's
warm or cold more okay okay all right
just the second number okay
now sometimes there's an idea of
embodied cognition and here's what it is
we can't really know how warm or cold
that person is or even that's even an
abstract idea but we know we're
comfortable when is we're kind of warm
and we know we're not comfortable
physically inside us when we're kind of
so there's an idea that when we think
about other people's feelings other
people's thoughts or abstract things in
the world we base them on physical
experiences that we have inside okay
there's a more direct link between what
we know inside us and we use that to
interpret the world out there embodied
cutting through your body is the vehicle
for understanding things out there so
here's here's the experiments they're
really clever there's two temperature
conditions so what happens is you go
into a building and the examiner an
undergraduate usually or graduate
student meets the subject in the lobby
and she's carrying or he's carrying a
cup of coffee sometimes it's hot coffee
sometimes it's cold coffee a clipboard
two textbooks okay so you can imagine
it's a setup right persons walk in
they're juggling with the coffee the
textbook all the clipboard right and
they says I'm the elevator says could
you just hold my cup while I write down
your name my my list of subjects in the
experiment okay it's very innocent right
on the elevator after you hold a cup of
coffee which half the people get a hot
cup half the people get a cold cup then
you read a description of a person it's
just a paragraph and you have to rate
whether you find the person described as
warm or cold and if you had the warm cup
of coffee you're more likely to describe
that person as a warm kind of a person
okay now these subjects have no idea
they held a cup of coffee they probably
didn't even think whether it was warm or
cold but something in their body they
got warmed up to the least degree
possible right that thought is still in
their head so when they read a
descriptions and they go oh this seems
like a warm person or if it was a cold
cup of coffee they say oh this seems
like a cold aloof kind of person as far
as I could tell all right that little
bit of difference so here's the lesson
just so you got it if you want to take
somebody because you have a possible
friendship a romantic interest in that
person yeah you better off going out for
a warm cup of coffee or giving them a
cold glass of beer but for that first
impression scientific research shows
it's a something warm we'll work it out
it's not that powerful you're not going
to be able to control the world okay
but you know what what it says is when
we are ambiguous situations ambiguous
situations
first meet somebody we don't really know
them little things can start us off on
one path can start us off another breath
surprisingly little things now then they
have to worry about a confound can you
imagine a count found here think of the
rats who knows if the cup is cold or hot
besides the person holding it the
examiner
right okay now maybe the examiner
doesn't try to do this but maybe the
examiner no matter what says over in the
warm condition and I'm smiling and this
is going to be nice I'm helping this
person feel good and here's the aloof
condition I'm giving it all gonna be
miserable yeah an examiner knows it
because they know if they have a hot or
cold cup of coffee so maybe the person's
not vibing to the coffee they're vibing
to the expression or feeling or
sentiment of the examiner right who
understands what's going on so they do
one more experiment where they give you
have you seen these hot and icy
therapeutic packs that you could make
hot or cold okay now somebody else makes
it hot or cold the experimenter has no
idea of whether it was hot or cold so
it's what we call double-blind the
person doesn't know it's relevant the
experimenter they rate the pad and now
this is this moves a little bit they
either get after this thing's already
told it's a product evaluation of the
pad but they either got a hot pad or a
cold pad and they could either choose to
one of two rewards a Snapple beverage or
a dollar gift certificate whichever you
like better okay you'd want two little
things you could do but here's the big
decision do you get it for yourself
where we can send it for you to a friend
we can send them the snap letour their
certificate if the people got a cold pad
75% of the times they say please give it
to me right now I'll take it if they had
a warm pad 46% of it you know the
majority of time they actually send it
to their friend that pad difference
moved you know quite substantially the
likelihood that you take it for yourself
or you give it away quite substantially
right if you're a charity trying to get
people to donate or you want to get help
from somebody a seventy-five you know
twenty five percent success rate is a
lot worse than a fifty four percent room
right it's a doubling a doubling of
whether you keep it for yourself or
you're generous to your friend just that
cup of coffee whether it's just that
that therapeutic pad I'm going to do two
more and then go debris or how about
money when you think about money I don't
mean traumatic thinks about money just a
little bit about money how does that
influence how you
relate to other people okay here's the
experiment the idea is that money on
average when you just think a little bit
about it and I'll show you how
ridiculously little they think about it
they think that their hypothesis that
money makes you think about
self-reliance you've earned your money
your bank account your age compared to
situations where you're not thinking
about money so here's here's what they
did they have people come in in three
conditions they either and they had to
unscramble sentences you have no idea
what's going on right you got a sentence
like cold it desk outside is which you
would make into a good sentence or high
a salary desk paying okay so you just
make this you scramble those words
around but the money condition has a
word like salary in it or you get the
neutral sentences that have no money
referenced and you see monopoly money in
the corner of the room okay so we're not
talking like people just sent you your
tuition bill okay
or whatever or do or you just found out
you know that you're you're you're
something terrible happened financially
or you won the lottery it's monopoly
money okay it's just like the idea of
money in them all right okay and then
they give you a task to do an experiment
or as he or she leaves the room and they
say it's a pretty hard task you may want
some help so just come and get me I'm
glad to help you not a problem so what
happens here's a probability of getting
help and it's incredibly more for the
control groups I got that did the
sentences without money and way less not
only for the people who unscramble the
sentence with the word salary but also
way less if they saw monopoly money in
the corner the mere idea of money not
money given to you not financial trauma
or financial gain the mere idea of money
makes you less willing to get up and get
help so the positive it makes you more
self-reliant the negative is it people
were less willing to help somebody said
now that the end as the examiner comes
in and says you know I'm an
undergraduate like you I've got huge
pressure to get this paper in can you
help me code but can you let me score up
a few sheets okay
people were twice as much willing to
help if they just did the neutral things
then if they scram scramble the money
sentences or saw the monopoly money in
the corners room
because just that thought about money
goes like man okay
self-reliance we're all in it for
ourselves okay yeah okay I've got my
money you've got your money you know
good luck you know we're all we're all
we're all okay
self-reliance can be a good thing but it
doesn't actually go with helping people
very much also yeah it could yeah the
monopoly money I agree with you is maybe
that's why they also had the one where
you just get the scrambled sentences
okay I do you think they're all you know
you could think there's many many ways
to think about this um okay the last
example does kinda want to show you is
dating behavior all right and the way
again an experiment can can challenge
various ideas so and this is
specifically about dating between men
and women the story to the extent study
would be a little bit different if
you're dating within a sex so for dating
between men and women who is more
selective in their dating choices do you
think who's more willing to date widely
or a lot or less you know what's your
thought if you have to generalize about
men and women on average in your now
okay thank you okay so an evolutionary
psychologist and I love evolutionary
psychology but it drives me crazy too
okay evolutionary psychologists well
because you know by evolutionary theory
men have to go and make as many
offspring as they can to keep their
genes going women have to be more
selective it takes nine months to bear a
baby
it takes nine seconds to do the male
part right okay estimated okay so so you
know so this might or might not be true
it's kind of fun we all laugh about I
always find it kind of amusing to sort
of think about you know if we say so but
how would we actually know if this is
vaguely true on average how would we
actually know if men for dating behavior
or how would we even on is that true is
that is that a you know bad myth that
bad rap or whatever yeah yeah thank you
very much so there's an entire research
enterprise out there now that uses
online dating sites which
since only in the last 20 years or
something you know that they've existed
I think so it wasn't before and the
other one that's been a treasure trove
of data a speed-dating environments okay
where you can observe things and measure
things and those studies have shown for
example that online dating on average
men are of one-and-a-half times more
likely to send email offering you know
dates to a woman than the other way
around
compared to women and in speed dating
two men are more likely to indicate
there would be happy to date a person
they met than women so there's objective
evidence that this is true on average in
the society at this time and so it
brings oh yeah this shows the
evolutionary psychology level issue
psychology as you crazy because in the
one hand it's certainly the case that
our minds and brains evolved through
evolution okay so there's something
about the history we went through as a
species that matters for who we are now
that's got to be the case on the other
hand it was a different world before
internet dating and speed dating right I
mean it's hard to know how those things
line up exactly so here's the fun thing
it turns out that on average and speed
dating a typical speed dating an event
will have like four minutes right so we
typically have women sitting at desks is
it almost always I set it up that way
and the men are sitting in chairs in
front the desk and they meet and they
talk for four minutes the bell rings the
men jump up and they shift over one
station right and then what happens is
for each time you meet a person you fill
out a card that says yes or no I'd be
willing to have a date with the person
and if you have two yeses from the man
and the woman the speed-dating organizer
exchanges the information so they can
make direct contact is that precise okay
all right and then make more us
responses and it turns out it doesn't
have to be this way but almost it was
from my reading that almost every
speed-dating thing as the men rotating
around okay and the women sitting there
waiting for the men to rotate around so
let's just ask this question what
happens if the women rotate which almost
never happens but they did this
experimentally they said for half of the
speed-dating sessions the men will be
sitting at the table and the women will
stand up and move a chair over every
formats the bell rings so the women are
moving and rotating and here's the
here's the results basically what's
showing on the left are when the men
rotate the standard condition that first
was romantic desire men
romantic desire on average for the
partner they sit with they feel that
more chemistry is happening with the
person they sit with and the underlay on
the bottom left corner they also are
more likely to give a yes response I
would like a date with this person okay
but reverse the roles have the women
rotating and look at these bars there's
no difference at all
you completely wipe out the male-female
difference in self-reported romantic
desire per person's self-reported
chemistry they think is happening and
the yes/no responses that I would have
at you completely eliminate it when the
women are rotating it's flat even so
what do you that's that that's the
result what do you what does it suggest
what happened to the evolutionary
psychology it disappeared just by having
the women rotate around the room it
suggests and we don't know this with
certainty but there people are following
this up who are interesting this it
suggests that there's something about
getting up and approaching that person
your body going here I come okay I'm not
sitting in my chair hanging out you know
it's like we're you know here I come
that makes a person energized feel more
romantic feel more chemistry is
happening and more likely to ask on a
date and it doesn't matter whether
you're a man or a woman at all okay it's
the getting up and that physical
approach just you're more invested
you're more out there who knows what it
is completely eliminates what everybody
had said is an ancient inevitable
evolutionary difference between men and
women and this isn't to say there might
not be some of those streaks in us who
knows but speed-dating is not showing
that okay all you got to do is have the
women rotate and you completely
eliminate what's thought to be some
hardwired biological difference on this
dimension now talking about that when we
do experiments like this that look at
sort of fun fun things like dating
around a thing or age difference between
a five year old and a 20 year old or 20
year old and 80 year old cultures
there's lots of experiments to compare
say Western cultures versus a Eastern
Asian cultures we'll talk about that
later in the course in terms of
behaviors genes whether you have one
gene or another all those things
are those independent variables no we
can't assign you randomly to be a man or
one younger old to come from the United
States or Japan or China or to have this
gene or that gene it's not that we
couldn't do stuff you know it's a
monstrous world but but not ethically
and it's never going to happen right so
so whenever you have science that talks
about differences between men and women
or young and old or cultures or genes
it's not really a completely independent
manipulation we can't assign you
randomly and so it means everything in
the world about what it means to be a
man or a woman a 20 year old or an 80
year old come from this continent or
that continent have this gene or that
gene those are not things we can freely
manipulate to be extra cautious
interpreting those kinds of studies
because we can't randomly assign you to
condition we just can okay and we I
didn't talk about the fact that we up
until this moment we made every
conclusion a complete generality about
human nature and people are different
one from the other individual
differences we'll talk about that later
in the course too so for the last couple
minutes I want to talk about this folk
psychology and you know everybody has
ideas about psychology so if you have
this piece of paper if you would zoom
through it ideas about people in
psychology and just where there is some
scientific evidence if you just zoom
down at mark yes or no on average do
opposites attract on average is familiar
breed contempt on average more people
President emergency are you more likely
to get some help on average are there
such things as visual learners and
verbal learners and if they got the
right kind of instruction that would
help them in school its hypnosis baloney
the subliminal advertising work you know
when things are presented so you don't
see them the low consciousness doesn't
help you buy something just playing
Mozart to an infant boost their
intelligent Mozart effect is old age on
average associated with this
satisfaction if you're unsure of your
answer when taking a test I'm going to
tell you the science about this it's
best to stick with your first hunch
practically every website tells you that
have you heard that many times okay I'm
going to tell you what the actual
evidence is about that how they get that
in a moment
ulcers are caused primarily by stress a
positive attitude can stave off cancer
raising children similarly leads to
similarities in their adult
personalities you know low self-esteem
is a major cause of psychological
problems people's responses and the
inkpot tests tell us a lot about
personalities interviews help identify
those most likely to succeed in medical
school okay I'll give you a minute okay
welcome a bunch of these will come back
to the course did the answer for all
these is this and there's evidence to it
also let me I'm going to tell you about
four of them for ten minutes okay well
one of the ones you might want to know
most about is the changing your initial
hunch answer okay how do you know that
so that people have gotten back over
test scores and look where people
crossed out an answer or erased an
answer that's the best source of
evidence they have on large samples and
people are twice as likely to give a
better the correct answer than to move
to a wrong answer that's the empirical
evidence okay so so it's a fantastically
interesting disconnect that you see so
many places and teachers advise you go
with your first hunch when you're unsure
the empirical evidence is you're much
more likely to be correct when you go
with your best final answer okay all
right having of course your get your not
sure says that you're going to miss a
fair bit but you're twice as likely to
come out with the correct answer when
you go with your best possible answer so
that people who crossed out their
answers or erase your answers there were
twice as likely to move to a good answer
then leave behind a good answer yeah
yeah there's an excellent question we
don't know they've kind of gone like
five times back and forth assumption has
been on average that that you know
people will go once back and forth but
you're right but but asking yourself the
other question - what's the evidence
ever that going with your hunches and
nobody's been able to show that okay so
where there's evidence is all in favor
of best answer and nobody's shown
evidence that hunch is the best way to
go empirically that doesn't mean that
sometimes it doesn't happen but on
average that's the way that ends go but
your question your ports excellent okay
so I
how about Rorschach test every
psychology program clinical psychologist
in the country is required to learn how
to administer an evaluator abortion you
know this so this obviously shows
obviously it shows some sort of horrible
sex act between animals and don't know
it's a yeah yeah you know these kinds of
tests you're so still read it in an
examiner listens to you and they figure
out something right okay you know
there's spend about 10,000 publications
of others there's no evidence that
there's anything predictive or correct
about this test none zero none okay
people argue it people give it you know
people have to learn how to give this
test so this is a disconnect that
happens a lot between clinical stuff and
experimental work I mean those you know
researchers don't can't grasp why people
still give this medical school interview
so those of you who will apply to
medical school will get interviews you
get interviews for jobs you can
introduce for all kinds of things in
your life what's the evidence that
interviews are any good for anything how
could you know whether interviews are
good for anything it a company
interviews you a university interviews
you how would you even decide whether so
I can tell you the social psychologists
have shown repeatedly that interviews
are cesspools for discrimination because
people tend to like people who are like
them okay yeah oh you went to MIT you
know yeah of course nine yeah you know
then you go oh man this is going to be
good right right or I went to Caltech we
didn't like MIT people we thought they
were a little bit snob years and they go
that's not gonna be so good or okay so
uh so you know socials and colleges have
shows if you're just very information
and practice interviews
people tend to people tend to like
people who are like them by background
by appearance and so on on average they
try not do they try to be fair but okay
so we know that but how about me okay so
here's what here's what they did
Yale compared students who were accepted
or rejection the basis of an interview
so they were all had scores that got
them to the interview and then they
looked at them where they went in pairs
or larger than pairs to other medical
schools so let's say you got accepted by
Yale and you were accepted or rejected
on the interview but you ended up as two
students at Penn or two students at
Michigan okay you're sitting next to
each other I'll just write one of you
was accepted by interview at Yale one of
who is not who does better at that other
place they're dead even the interview
added nothing for predicting grade point
average or completion of medical school
here's one more example University of
Texas enlarged in the midst of their
Houston in the midst of their interviews
it enlarged from 150 to 200 students
they had interviewed 800 the 50 who came
were among their top ones they
interviewed them they liked them that
came and then they had and all of a
sudden because the state legislature
said by law
Mandana you take 50 more they took 50
more who didn't do so well in the
interview okay those 50 more performed
identically to the ones who got in with
a successful interview they couldn't
find a difference between them now
there's at least one thing you might
think the interview might have done but
we don't know but that's but people what
do you think it might have done so these
the outcome was your grades in medical
school and your likelihood of completing
medical school what else could an
interview have been relevant for
maybe maybe maybe something about
bedside manner or how you relate to
people maybe maybe maybe but there's no
evidence that that's true okay now
you're starting to grasp at straws so
there's no evidence that interview
processes make any difference anywhere
but everybody does interviews all the
ways because we always think we're kind
of good judges of human nature or
something okay so so interviews it's
very hard to tell that they ever do
anything so here's my last thing
self-esteem you cannot watch you know
Oprah or dr. Phil without some
discussion of self-esteem at some moment
and it sounds good to everybody I mean
nobody would wish for you as a parent or
friend for you to low self-esteem and in
fact higher self-esteem is correlated
with higher initiative and persistence
happiness and emotional resilience and
also unfortunately with people who are
narcissistic and bullies okay I mean I
mean on average isn't and how they
measure it just so you know because this
is a problem - like how do you measure
it you have the there's several scales
but the most widely you scale is this
Rosenberg scale so you have that - if
you want to try it out on yourself okay
okay self-report and when they reviewed
15,000 studies some years ago they could
find no evidence that higher self-esteem
leads to better things
it all seemed the other way around that
like doing better at things led to
higher self-esteem okay they could never
find that pushing yourself esteem up
doesn't having said that I can tell you
as a parent of two young kids or if you
have friends and you care about them and
you know this we like to praise people
to build up their self-esteem right what
tells you you're awesome now someday
you'll go to MIT I knew you will okay
you're wonderful person and you're smart
and you're beautiful and you know
parents want their children and teachers
to to grow up and thrive and build up
that self-esteem so how could and the
easiest way to do that is praise right
just tell you your kid how awesome he or
she is or your younger sibling how
awesome he or she is get their
self-esteem up so the last thing I'm
tell you and then we'll be done in about
three minutes is we're from Carol Dweck
that shows you how danger it is how to
encounter productive it is to have you
know praise where you don't think
through its relation to people and in
one sentence we'll talk about are you
going to succeed in life by your effort
or by your talent you know what's a
bigger question than that wherever you
get to in your life is going to be based
on your effort or your talent or both
I'll just have a sentence about there
now but
so here's the experiment she did with
5th graders she had them form a pretty
hard task and afterwards randomly they
were either praised for their
intelligence so person said to them you
fifth grader you are so smart I can't
believe how great you did on that okay
or they were praised for the hard work
this shows a lot of hard work
okay different kid and some kids got no
praise at all
in this experiment okay now then they
get any task that's even a little bit
harder how does the different kind of
praise influence things and here was to
finding if you are praised for your
intelligence you did worse on the second
test if you were praised for your hard
work you did better if nobody said
anything your performance didn't change
and the idea is this you understand
praise for your intelligence you did
worse on a hard task praise for your
effort you did better and here's the
idea that if we praise people for their
intelligence to build up their
self-esteem they start to care more
about how their performance reflects on
them than the performance itself because
if I you're trying to prove that you're
an intelligent person you care less use
people the students who get that kind of
praise for their intelligence they
persist less than a difficult task
they say it's they don't enjoy
challenges why they just want to ace
everything to keep proving they're smart
okay
the kids who get praised for effort
they're kind of like okay I'm going to
make some mistakes but I'm just going to
keep going because with effort I can do
things sometimes and it turns out that
it makes a remarkable thing and so Dweck
will come back this talks about you can
view your intelligence as a trait I have
only so much or as a growth the harder I
work the smarter I get but I have to do
the hard work to get there okay and we
live in a society that often goes by
fixed traits American Idol the harder to
work the better than you sing or who has
the talent is discovered who has the
talent is discovered right okay right
because the idea is you know you're a
certain amount of musical talent and now
the judges show and you break into the
world and you're a famous singer right
um
so ask yourself this when you are good
at what you do is it because something
in your genes in an environment made you
good at it because you try really hard
so Malcolm Gladwell has a state
that's floating around gets a lot of
attention that anybody can become great
at anything if they work on it for
10,000 hours so how much of your success
in the past currently in the future is
going to be based on your effort then
how much is it going to be based on your
talents and how would we know that and
we're very talent oriented in society it
seems like the more we encourage effort
maybe the more people might flourish so
we talked about how psychology and
science experiments brief history of
psychology experimentation some issues
and experimentation them and some
psychological topics and some practical
information for being generous and kind
and winning friends rapidly okay thanks
very much
you